[Music]
PJ Tucker was the undisputed Kix King
last season on any given night
the Rockets three-point threat Rock
nothing but heat on his feet
even Michael Jordan wanted to know where
pj copped his exclusive J's so who's
gonna compete for the sneaker throne
this year
kyrie irving's be showing off mad
flavors of his cereal inspires signature
shoe with the killer crossover and fire
kicks to match you know Uncle Jim can't
wait for his shoes to eat on the court
[Applause]
Lance Stephenson is bringing an arsenal
of custom kicks to Hollywood the
Brooklyn native isn't shy about wearing
the hottest kicks in the game and born
ready made it known he wants that
sneaker title the sneaker collection is
out of here nobody come on King James
had the whole world on LeBron watch with
classic colorways of the LeBron 15 the
legends took notice and fans couldn't
wait for the next drop with a new season
in a new city and the LeBron six teams
on the way LA bran might add the kicks
crown jewel to his kingdom
so who do you think will step up and
challenge PJ Tucker a sneaker chin
[Applause]